- I think we're very close
to augmented reality.
I think all four of us are going to
have a piece of content in 36 months,
36 months
that has us and our created pet in it.
- [Female] A virtual pet.
(hip hop music)
- I think we're very close to
having a cartoon partner in our lives.
Let me explain.
Snapchat's kind of studio
I think we're very close
to augmented reality.
I think where we go with that is
your pet.
I think we're all gonna
I think all four of us are gonna have
a piece of content in 36 months,
36 months, that has us
and our created pet in it.
- [Female] A virtual pet.
Going back to
- A virtual something.
So I have a meeting today with my team,
and I'm gonna create, basically,
a Disney World of characters
that we're gonna design
and are gonna show up in my content
because you can.
Literally,
Sacha the sneaker
is like a sneaker
character and
I'm gonna use him for
all my sneaker stuff.
We should make Airport Gary right away.
I want you to design Sacha the sneaker.
No Grandma Vee yet.
Like, Larry the Librarian
to support me on the books.
See where I'm going?
We know my world.
- [Male] A DJ character for
all your music stuff.
- Hundred percent.
Like a marshmallow-like.
Maybe his head should be the five.
(laughs)
I actually think I like that idea.
And by the way, we're gonna make
we're gonna design them in Snapchat,
we're gonna use them in DailyVee.
Like when I make fun of
Rick and Sally, naturally,
their little heads'
gonna pop up and be like,
you know?
I genuinely think this is the
next big IP space.
I think in 36-48 months,
that's where this all goes.
You guys all have your own Tamagotchi
kind of like
you're gonna all have your own character.
I think Instagram Stories is like
more reach now than real, actual reach.
- [Anthony] You see more
the amount of viewers that you get on your
Snapchat story, compared to the
amount of followers you had,
compared to your posts' organic reach
is much higher just because of where it is
and like Instagram.
So it's much easier to look
through the top circles
than it is just the feed.
So, you actually see
your followers see your Snapchat,
Instagram stories more
than your actual feed,
and your actual posts.
- [Gary] I'm aware.
- Yeah, so
it definitely makes sense why.
I know just from like a branding,
everyone
shout outs on Instagram
have been less about feed posts
and more about just stories.
So companies have just been using stories.
- [Gary] I'm aware.
- Yeah.
- [Gary] Like, literally
my sneaker
was what, November?
Yeah, November.
And the book was
Feb, Jesus Christ,
January, right.
In that eight weeks,
I went from being pissed that people
were giving me shout outs
for the sneaker in the story,
to wanting them to give
it to me in the story.
Eight weeks.
But the number one thing that I think
can change our game really fast
is community management
and the cool thing is
I think everybody should do it,
'cause it's the quickest way to learn
what's actually happening here.
It's just like, listening
is different than replying.
Think about how much I believe in
community management.
My second book was The Thank You Economy.
I don't know what else to tell you.
(hip hop music)
So how long were you at
- Two years.
- And then what did
- About two years.
- Oh really?
- Well, 18 months.
- You held on, you didn't want to
you knew right away?
- I knew within two weeks.
- And you were like, fuck.
- Yeah, so I get to do
- You were hacking away to make it worth
your while for the year?
- Yeah.
- 'Cause you didn't want
to bounce so quickly
on the resume?
- Yeah.
I just thought
- I gotta make some content around that.
I don't think it's as big of a deal
as people think.
- You know, it's funny that you say that
because I was with some guys who are in
finance and real estate this weekend,
and I made a comment about that.
We were talking about this exact stuff.
And they were like,
I don't know if that matters.
And I thought personally, realistically,
if I can have a conversation with someone
and say, look,
this is why it didn't work out
but I did what I could,
and we swung and missed three times
- I don't think it matters.
- Yeah.
- I'm gonna make a piece
of content about that.
- I think that's interesting.
- I have a quick video rant to make.
_ [Female] Oh right now?
- Well, I'm gonna finish here
but because of this, yeah.
(laughs)
Hey guys,
something's been emerging
just came out of a great
meeting with a young winner
in my company.
This is just a random piece of content
I think is gonna help a lot of people.
I think a lot of people
are staying in jobs
for one or two years,
after they realize the job sucks
or is not for them,
two or three weeks in.
And I think the reason they're doing that
is they're worried that it's gonna
look bad on their resume.
And I just don't think that's as real
as people think in today's environment.
I just don't know what else to say.
To me, the way I look at it is number one,
if a company looks at your
resume when you submit it
and sees that you only worked
somewhere for two months,
and that eliminates you,
you probably don't want
to work for that company.
Number two, if you get in the door,
you can just explain that
you used your self awareness to recognize
it wasn't a good fit,
or you undercovered this or this
or the other thing or you were
sold a bag of goods that weren't real.
Just the thought of people in their 20's
wasting two years, because
they want their resume
to not look awkward
to then get another job at a place that
would judge you on that resume
just feels like one big shit circle.
So, recommendation of the day,
don't overthink it.
If the job sucks, bounce.
It's not gonna really fuck up your resume
in the world that we're
actually living in.
- We wanna jumpstart
the social media thing.
We want to, basically just come here
and just talk to you.
- Sure.
- What we have going on,
and just hear your thoughts.
- So YouTube, Facebook, Instagram
his channels blew up immediately,
because he had just went across games,
want to start following him.
- Yeah of course.
- Content was
skyrocketing, right?
And
- But you were taking all that energy
and putting into the gyms
instead of the brand.
Makes sense, it's 2008.
- The awkward is
so for example is that he has 50 thousand
followers on YouTube.
But we only get a few
hundred hits on videos, so
we're feeling stale
we're trying to reactivate these
- You know what's amazing?
This will get you very excited.
I don't think I was much further along
three and a half years
ago when I got serious.
- Yeah.
- I had my thing,
I was winning, good things were happening.
But I think I was at
48 thousand subscribers
on YouTube.
- Yeah.
- I was at 34 thousand
Instagram followers.
I was big on Twitter,
'cause that's where I come from.
- Right.
- But I was
head down in building Vayner.
I got rebooted
D-Rock started three years ago,
I guess maybe four
I got rebooted somewhere
in three and a half,
four years ago.
And it happened really fast.
So it's funny,
I think I was at a very
a lot of people
I'm in a very good spot right now.
- Yeah.
- But three and half, four years ago
I was in a stale point
for a personal brand.
- Right, mmhmm.
- You need to start thinking of yourself
as a media company.
I'm sure you guys, it seems
you know enough about me
to know, there's nothing
I think I'm gonna tell you
that's maybe something
you've never heard before.
You need to have written,
audio and video formed content
being put out at scale, every fuck
you have to understand.
Here's the thing.
It's a land grab.
Is it as easy
to become a CrossFit celebrity today
as it was in 2008?
No.
Supply and demand.
- Right.
- The supply and demand of
awareness and attention
in this device
across the 11 platforms that matter
will never be better than it is right now.
- Right.
- And it's not as good
as it was yesterday.
- Right.
- Got it?
- Yeah.
- If you look at the
personalities that win,
we're never in the same spot.
This guy jumps this one,
this girl jumps that guy,
this guys goes down, this guy goes up.
It all happens based on who's best
at the thing that matters the most
at the time.
- Right, right.
- But here's what I'm saying.
Moments in time.
- Right.
- Instagram, podcasts,
LinkedIn, I'm very bullish on.
All this stuff,
you have to have a podcast,
you have to have written form,
you have to have a vlog,
you have to have them.
(modern rap music)
Airport Gary,
ready in full effect.
Toronto, I'm comin' serious!
Good day, got a lot done.
Very energized.
VaynerSports had a big day.
That feels good.
And, fuckin' VaynerMedia, man.
Vayner X.
The whole Vayner X empire,
PureWow, big ups.
Secret projects for the summer.
(rap music)